두 분 나오신다고 그래서
요즘은 얼마나 편하길래
애널리스트가 지금
지금 보고서 안 쓰고
여기 방송에 나와있나
저는 이상한 매니저들을 가끔 만나요
이상한 매니저가 부르는 건
애널리스트가 이상한 거예요
어떤 분들이 가끔 계시냐면
이제 모 본부장님께서
위원님은 혹시
금융위기 때 몇 살이었어요?
나이 공격?
보고서를 쓰는 애널리스트는
아무리 어려도
연구원님, 위원님, 사장님도 그래요
인정하는 거지
난 그건 인정한다
그런데 셀레포트로 써 이 새끼야?
이러면서
내가 들고 있는데 이 놈의 새끼
윤쌤이 이제 주식 전리하시니까
윤쌤이 볼 때는 금리가 하락해
나는 금리 오른다는 보고서를 쓰는 거예요
하우스비로 다르게 가져가요?
아니 난 모르고 썼지
나한테 얘기를 안 해주니까
자기의 소신일 수도 있잖아요
막내 PD님이 들어오셨는데
니뉴님한테
저희 프로그램 방향성 그거 아닌 것 같은데요
저는 그렇게 생각 안 하고
이렇게 가시죠
뭐라고 말씀하실까요?
그렇게 말을 할 수 있다고?
그러니까요
안녕하십니까
개미는 지금의 니뉴입니다
또 이렇게 게스트로 모셨는데
어디 사는 누구시죠?
저는 여의도 사는
알렉스고요
지금은 약간 유튜버 하고 있고요
그래서 오늘 두 분 나오신다고 해서
약간 들어보려고
요즘은 얼마나 편하길래
애널리스트가 지금
지금 보고서 안 쓰고
방송에 나와 있나
이런 생각 한번 들어보려고
애널리스트의 잡조리
현재 국내 최고 애널리스트
그리고 전 애널리스트
최고의 두 분을 모셨습니다
우선 우주자로 우리 유명하신
정의훈 애널리스트님
소개 부탁드리겠습니다
네 안녕하십니까
저 유진투자증권에서
우주산업 담당하고 있는
애널리스트 정의훈입니다
오늘은 유진투자증권의
애널리스트 들어온 게 아니라
개미 정의훈으로 왔습니다
아 좋아
준비물도 가져오셨잖아요
원래 개미들끼리 얘기할 때는
뭐가 필요하냐면
마실거리가 필요합니다
그래도 음주 방송은 좀 얘기가 아니라서
넌알코올맥주
카스 광고주 보고 계신가요?
죄송한데 저희 PD님이세요
와 진짜 진심이시구나
근데 진심치고는
요즘에 틀면 나오던데
아니 뭐 여기 와서는
슈카님 최고고
알상무님이 베스트 애널리스트
내 생에 최고의 애널리스트
이렇게 말씀하셔놓고
손에 잡히는 게
경제 어디 경제
연합뉴스 막 다 나오시더라고
요즘에 너무 바쁘시죠
제 마음속 고마운 채널 1등이
머니코믹스에요
에이 또 또 또
아니 머니코믹스를 전후로 나뉘어졌어요
잠깐만 안될가왕 나가서
내 인생 최고의 채널을
확실히 머니코믹스를 나가고 나서
방송 섭외가 되게 많아졌고
심지어 그 PD님들도
거기 요청사항이
머니코믹스처럼 해주세요
뭐야
머니코믹스처럼 편하게 해주세요
근데 제가 그게 잘 안 되는 거예요
그게 역시 니뉴님의 감초 역할이 되게 중요하구나
옆에서 약간
그치 그치 약간 이런 거가
사람을 되게 신나게 해요
걸렸네 걸렸어
아 그리고 저도 사실 처음 뵙는 분이에요
유튜브에서도 처음 뵙고
우리 연구원님 의원님이 소개를 해주셔가지고
이렇게 출연을 하시게 됐는데
네 안녕하세요 저는
PTR자산운용에서 주식운용력으로 근무하고 있는
강대석이라고 하고요
이전에는 이제 정혁연구원이랑 같이 유진증권에서
또 시황결자 애널리스트로 글을 썼었고
그 이후에는 또 잠깐 유한타증권에서
주식시황 애널리스트로 근무를 했었습니다
오 반갑습니다
그러면 매니저라는 건 어떤 역할을 하시는 거예요?
이제 포트폴리오를 관리하는 거죠
셀사이드에 계시다가 알사이드로 처음 가시는 거죠
PTR자산운용은 저도 좀 알거든요
근데 약간 좀 생소할 수 있어요 개인분들한테
저희가 이제 PER, PBR 많이 쓰시잖아요
그런 개념으로 PTR이라고 해서
T는 이제 테크놀로지라고 하는 말이고
저희는 특허가치를 기반으로 이제 계산을 해서
지금 이제 시가총액하고 특허가치하고 계산을 해봤을 때
어떤 특허가치 대비 저평가돼 있는 기업들이 뭔가
아니 사실 저번에 방송 나오셔서
우리나라 3대
애널리스트 중에
제가 존경하는
존경하는 3대 애널리스트
누구죠?
첫 번째가 이승우 센터장님
저희 회사의 서치센터 센터장님
2대가 알상문님
3대가 저희 김광진 선배님
가수 김광진 선배님
그분도 원래 애널리스트였어요
맞아요
아 진짜요?
펀드매니저도 하고
너무 힘들어서 때려쳤어
제가 존경하는 애널리스트 특징은
애널리스트 업무도 잘하시지만
다재다능한
한 곳에서만의 두각을 나타내는 것 같아요
저도 잘생긴 사람을 존경하시네요
죄송합니다
오늘 애널리스트 특집이잖아요
특집
애널리스트 전 친구분이신 거예요?
애니저 경험도 같이 있는 분이면 좋겠다 싶어서
너무 좋아요
제가 요청을 했어요
장중회였는데 갑자기 전화와서
장중회
사무실에 있으면
어 위원님
이러고 이제 전화를 받거든요
사담하면 또 그렇지
위원님 이러면서 이제
통화를 할 수 있는 부스나 회의실로 갑니다
아 이거 회사에서 보면 안 되는데
그러고 이제 가서 얘기를 하는데
갑자기 대뜸 전화가 와서
아 형 뭐 팟캐스트 같은 거 하나 나갈 건데 괜찮지?
같이 나간다고 한다
아 선배가 또 그렇게 된 걸로
왜냐면 제가 또 말 잘하시는 분
좋은 분 좀 추천을 해드릴게요
해달라고 했거든요
애널리스트는 기본적으로 말을 잘해요
맞아요
그게 말 못 하다가도
어차피 말하는 게 제업이거든요
말을 못 하는 사람도 거기 살아남으려면
설득력 있게 자료는 하지만
자료 사실 안 보거든요
매니저 이놈들 안 봐
맞아요
애널리스트의 적은 매니저
아 그래요?
매니저가 우리 각이거든
아 나 그 구조도 좀 궁금했어요
그러니까 누가 누구에게 잘 보여야 되고
먹고 먹히는 관객인데
제가 애널리스트란 직업에 대해서
잠깐 말씀을 드릴게요
오 좋아
우선 애널리스트는
증권사 리서치
내에서 분석가라고
생각을 하시면 될 것 같아요
보통 애널리스트가
증권가의 꽃이라고도 불리기도 했는데
최근에 좀 많이 시들긴 했습니다
왜 그러냐면
리서치 센터가 결국에는
회사 입장에서 보면
비용 부서입니다
돈을 못 벌어오는 부서
제가 아무리 보고서를 열심히 써도
보고서가 팔리지 않는 이상
보고서로 돈을 벌 순 없어요
보고서를 팔아요?
파는 데도 있죠
돈 내야지 보고서를 볼 수 있는
하우스들도 있어요
근데 국내 증권사는
아마 거의 대부분
유료로 풀리는 건 없고
그런 건 있어요
자기 회사 쓰는 고객들한테만
가입하면 이제 일부 나오는데
저희가 아무래도
수익을 직접적으로 창출하는 건
아니기 때문에
좀 비용 부서라는 인식이 좀 있습니다
그럼 우리의 일과는 뭐가 되냐면
보고서를 쓰는 것도 있지만
회사에 도움이 돼야 돼요
여러 방면으로 돼야 되거든요
일단 첫 번째는
펀드매니저들한테 가서
세미나를 서비스를 해주는 거예요
아 이런 분들한테
운용사 입장에서는
증권사로부터 서비스를 받으면
거기에 대한 보은이랄까요
그래서 주식 주문을 얻습니다
단순히 뭐 레포트를 써줬으니까
이게 아니라
등급을 다 매겨요
증권사 입장에서는
주문량이 늘어나면
수수료가 많이 늘어나잖아요
그렇게 해서 돈을 버는 데
기여할 수도 있고요
심지어는 채권 애널리스트는
그러니까 주식은 조금
상관관계가 좀 불분명한 경우가 있어요
100억 더 나온다고
그 영업부서에서 그렇게 좋아하지 않잖아요
근데 채권은
만약에 내가 가서
커브를 잘 설명했어
그래서 베팅해서 먹었어
그럼 바로 3천 개 주문 들어옵니다
주문 주면서 그래요
야 누구 때문에 주는 거다
이렇게 얘기해요
그러면 그 영업부서에서는
그 애널리스트를 고마워하면서
아낄 수밖에 없지
그러면 연봉이 올라가
그쵸
나갑니다 그러면
영업부서 본부장이 찾아
얼마면 되냐
그럽니다
대박이다
저쪽에서 한 5천
올려준다
그럼 이제
그건 맞춰줘 우선
맞춰주고 더 주냐 안 주냐
아 그럼 애널리스트가
그냥 공부만 하는 사람이 아니고
그래서 제가
취업 상담 같은 걸 할 때도 있어요
애널리스트가 되려면 어떻게 해야 되냐
아 그니까
근데 제가 뭐라 말씀드리냐면
내가 연구하는 거 좋아하고
가만히 있는 거 좋아하고
그러면 적성이 오히려 안 맞아요
세미나도 다녀야 되고
자기가 영업을 해야 되는
맞아요 내 자료를 영업을 해야 되고
내 자료가 좋다라는 걸
전달도 잘 할 줄 알아야 되는데
학구열이 강한 사람이라고 하면
안 맞을 수도 있어요
그러면 세 분은
공부도 엄청 잘하고
영업도 잘하고
사람도 잘 만나고
발표도 잘하고
그냥 다재다능하신
꼭 그렇진 않고요
그런 분들은 연봉이 높으신 분들이고요
그래서 좀 슬픈 게
애널리스트 분들 중에서
수익 구조가 연봉이 다예요
그러니까 저희가 성과 베이스가 없어요
진짜?
그러니까 예를 들면
이건 근데 하우스마다 좀
하우스마다 다르죠
하우스마다 다른데
보통은 예를 들면
어떤 IB 부서 같은 경우에는
수익이 얼마만큼 벌어졌다라는 게
부서가 이게 지표가 있잖아요
레이셔가 정해져 있지 않죠
그렇죠
주명 땡큐고
맞아요 약간 성과급이 있긴 있는데
보통은 이제 연봉 계약할 때
잘 해야 돼요
불러먹어줄 때도 있어
돈을 안 주고
불먹 한 대 더 놔둘 때도 있어
RA 붙여줄게
맞아요
내 RA인 줄 알았는데
다 같이 쓰고 있어요
맞아요
그럼 매니저님은 한 몇 년 하셨어요?
애널리스트
리서치에는 한 6, 7년 정도 있었는데
이제 RA 한 거 빼고
애널 한 거만 치면 한 5년 정도
그럼 6, 7년 있다가 매니저로 가면
확실히 이 연봉 체계
다른 게 느껴지나요?
그렇죠 아무래도 이제
바이사이드 쪽으로 넘어오면
기본금 좀 줄고
이제 인센에 대한 기대치가 좀 올라가는
숫자로 작년에 몇 프로 했다가
정확히 나오기 때문에
애널리스트랑 좀 다른
그런 성과급 구조가 있습니다
와
아니 그래서 의윤 매니저님이
요즘 방송 되게 열심히 하시네요
몸값을 올리려는 어떤
제2의 인생을 향한 어떤 욕심이 아닌가
저는 그런 사실 쪽보다는
이제는 애널리스트도
자기 브랜드가 있어야 된다고 생각을 해요
좋은 자료들이 너무 많고
AI가 등장하면서
일을 대체할 수 있는 분들도
이제 굉장히 좀 많아졌기 때문에
맞다
결국에 제가 중요하게 생각하는 건
좋은 자료를 쓰는 건 당연하고
그리고 이거를 시청자분들이나
혹은 투자자분들이나
혹은 기관분들에게
전달을 잘 할 수 있는
어떤 브랜드를 만들자라는 측면에서
요즘 좀 열심히 활동하고 있습니다
뭐야
아 센터장님 보고 계신 거 같은데
센터장님 씨
재밌어야 돼요
애널리스트가 와서 설명했는데
내가 혼나고 가는 거 같아
제가 매니저 생활도 꽤 했으니까
불렀는데 나한테 가르치고 가
맞아 얘 말이 맞아
근데 이제 보팅할 땐 안 줘
저는 좀 반대예요
저는 이상한 매니저들을 가끔 만나요
이상한 매니저가 부르는 건
애널리스트가 이상한 거예요
이상한 매니저들이 이상한 매니저
애널리스트를 좋아해
대부분의 매니저님들이 나이스하시고
예의 바르시고 되게 잘 들어주시는데
이제 어떤 분들이 가끔 계시냐면
어 한 번 말해봐
해봐
맞아
이렇게 팔짱 끼고
진짜로?
싸가지 아니야 그거는
그리고 트집을 막 잡아요
맞아요
저는 약간 하면서도 자괴감이 들 때가 있어요
그게 되게 힘들어
왜 부른 거지 이럴 거면
아 이럴 거면
알잖아 포트에 없어서 그래
아
추천 종목이
어제 목표가 올렸는데 내가 포트에 없어
그런 경우가 있어요
bm에서 밀리고 있단 말이야
내가 이 종목이 궁금해서 부르는 것도 있는데
네가 이걸 왜 미는 거야
나를 좀 설득시켜봤는데
이미 삔돈 상한 거지
저도 예전에 이닛한 지 얼마 안 됐을 때
네
이닛은 이제
RA는 자기 이름 못 내거든요
애널리스트가 돼야 낼 수 있어요
아 입궁이라고 하죠
데뷔를 하고 처음으로 이제 뭐 세미나를 다닐 때
이제 매크로 쪽 전략 쪽은
약간 시니어분들이 많으세요
맞아요
보통 팀장급 본부장님들 분들이 많으신데
형님들
이제 모 본부장님께서
아 위원님은 혹시 금융위기 때 몇 살이었어요
와
나이 공격?
바로 거기서부터 무슨 말인지 하나도 기억 안 나고요
막 공격해야지 맞다이 쳐야지
그럼 몇 살이셨는데 그때
그게 안 되는 게 고객사예요
싸우려면 이제
확실히
이거나
돌아가서 불려갈 각오를 해야지
와
그래서 만약에 애널리스트도 정말 잘하시는 분들은
이제 체급이 되시니까
그런 분들은 오히려 쳐낼 수 있는데
저 같은 이제 학고 애널리스트들은
쭈구리처럼
쭈구리
그건 아니고요
절서고 이제
제가 죄송합니다 이러면서 이제 뒤에서 이제 눈물 훔치는 거예요 이제
어떡해
근데 애널리스트가 약으로 치면 투수 같은 거예요
잘하면 연봉 엄청 높고
아무도 건들지 않아
못하면 바로 잘려요
저는 절대 기상일보 욕 안 해요
아 그거 좀 틀릴 수도 좀 있지
아니 그거 다 어떻게 맞춰요
그렇게 많이 틀려요
네
그때 윤쌤님이 나오셔가지고
알상문은 냅두라고
냅둬 약간 이런 애널리스트들이 있다고
이게 사람과 사람 간의 일이다 보니까
본인이 마음이 가는 애널리스트가 더 있을 수밖에 없어요
그렇지
본인 눈에 눈밖에 난 애널리스트가 있을 수밖에
왜 눈밖에 나지
이게 저희가 일반적인 회사랑 너무 다른 게
애널리스트 하나하나가 전부 다 개인 사업자라고 보시면 돼요
팀 내에 팀장님이 있어도
팀장님이랑 일주일, 이주일 동안 말 한마디도 안 할 때가 있어요
왜냐면 그분은 그분 담당 산업이 있고
저는 제 산업이 있으니까
제가 하루 종일 자리에 없어도 팀장님은 저를 안 찾으세요
저희가 그리고 파티전도 되게 높아서
사람 키만 해요
낮으면 책을 싸 막 책을 싸가지고
안 봐
맞아요
그래서 되게 프리하거든요
제가 예를 들면 일과 시간에 집에 간다고 해도
아무도 잘 안 찾으세요
그렇지
반대로 얘기하면
제 성과가 그대로 드러나는 게 이 직업이에요
제가 예를 들면 보고서 개수나 세미나 횟수나
활동적인 부분이 부족하면
팀 탓을 못하고
제가 오로지 다 감내를 해야 되는 거예요
그래서 애널리스트분들이
자유로움에도 불구하고 일을 더 많이 하세요
와 프로다 프로 진짜
뭐 야근 많이 하시고
주말에 나가면 항상 계시고
그래서 좀 되게 워라벨을 생각하시면
애널리스트는 하시면 안 됩니다
근데 아까 알상문님 말씀하셨는데
말씀 들어보니까
요즘 애널리스트들이 퇴근이라는 걸 한다면서
라고 하시더라고요
깜짝 놀랐습니다
옛날엔 뭐 퇴근이라는 게 없었나요?
퇴근 출근의 개념이 없죠
보고서가 내일 아침까지 나와야 되면
죽어라고 쓰는 거야
50분 전까지 쓰는 거야
물론 에디트하고 나가는 경우도 있지만
어쨌든 처음에 내리는 건 나와야 되니까
저는 이제 수도 없이 이런 테이블에서 잤습니다
라꾸라꾸 갖다 놓으신 분들
아니 라꾸라꾸도 놓을 수 없었고
저희는 대형 회의실
큰 탁자 있잖아요
거기서 3, 4명이 자고
제가 반박해드릴게요
왜요?
왜 그럴 수밖에 없는지
이게 다릅니다
옛날에는
아 옛날이라고 하면 좋겠나?
애널리스트의 리포트의 영향력이 컸어요
맞아요
과거로 갈수록
애널리스트가 리포트를 썼을 때 영향력이 크다 보니까
회사에서도 애널리스트를 잡기 위한 연봉을 많이 줬었어요
지금은 좀 낮아졌어요?
지금은 매우 낮아졌어요
아 진짜요?
그러다 보니까 이게 둘 중 하나여야 되는 거예요
돈을 안 받고 너무 미친듯이 일을 하거나
아니면 좀 덜
왜냐면 미친듯이 일하시는 분들은 결국 나가세요
더 좋은 곳으로 나가거나
아니면 이걸 포기하고 나가시는 거다 보니까
다트 공시 보거나 뭐 이러셨을 때
윤봉킹이나 이런 거에서 애널리스트 보신지 오래돼요
없긴 해
예전에는 진짜 많이 받는 분은
10억도 나오기도 하고 그랬었는데
요즘은 이제 공시에는 거의 대부분 이제 PB분들
아니면 이제 채권 쪽
아니 그러면 사실 이제 매니저님도 애널리스트 하다가 매니저님 가셨고
우리 의훈 연구원님도 뭔가 꿈꾸고 있는 어떤
지금 상당히 약간 불만이 조금 있으신 것 같거든요?
저는 회사에 대한 불만이라기보다는
좀 애널리스트 직업에 대한 불만이 좀 있어요
왜요?
그러니까 애널리스트 직업에 대한 불만이 좀 있어요
애널리스트를 너무 옥죄는 것 같아요
누가?
우리 사회가
사회적 압박을 받고 있어요?
이거 바로 여러분
아 당신네론이야
아니 농담입니다
아니 왜 그러냐면
애널리스트에 대한 기대치, 눈높이 혹은 그런 제한들은 여전해요
근데 사회는 되게 많이 변했잖아요
그런데 그거 변화를 많이 못 따라가는 것 같아요
예를 들면 대표적으로
니니님이 종목 추천을 자유롭게 할 수 있지만
저는 그걸 하면 잡혀가요
물론 애널리스트라는 직업 자체가 전문적으로 이걸 분석하는 거다 보니까
보고서에 따른 책임감은 있어야 된다고 생각해요
보고서에 따른 책임감은 있어야 된다고 생각하는데
예전처럼 리포트가 가지는 영향력이 많지가 않아요
제가 예를 들면 네이버에 자료를 썼다고 해서
주주분들이 그걸로 인해서 큰 영향을 저는 안 미친다고 생각하거든요
그래도 우리 목표 주가 같은 거 많이 보는데
근데 그 목표 주가마저도 제약이 많이 걸리다 보니까
시청자분들이 흔히들 많이 비판하는
그저그런 보고서
쌓인 게 많았네
나왔다 나왔다 나왔다
다 얘기하고
쌓인 게 많았네
그저그런 보고서가 나올 수밖에 없는 이유가
튀는 보고서를 냈을 때 메리트가 없어요
여기서 말하는 튀는 보고서라고 하는 것은
예를 들면 A라는 종목의 주가가
두 배가 갈 것 같다 세 배가 갈 것 같다
라고 썼을 때
본인이 들어간 종목도 아닌데
그렇게 세게 콜을 했을 때는
피를 볼 수밖에 없어요
떨어지면 더 문제예요
그리고 만약에 내가 이 종목이
셀 리포트를 썼어요
틀려도 문제고 맞아도 문제예요
왜요? 왜왜왜?
그거는 제 메일함을 보시면 됩니다
자료화면이 하나 있는데
쇼 포지션 받았는지 의심됩니다
금감원에 정식으로 수사 의뢰하겠습니다
악의적인 리포트 저희가 의심됩니다
땡땡땡아
아
근데 이런 거 진짜 받으면 멘탈 나갈 것 같아요
저런 건 오히려 웃으면서 넘어가고 있어요
그래요?
어떤 사람들이 있냐면
호초리 하나하나 잡으면서
훈수를 주는 메일들이 있어요
메일이 와요?
그분들은 이미 이성을 잃으신다
심지어 어떤 적도 있었냐면
왜 너 바이를 더 세게 안 외쳐
바이를 했는데
그래서 제가 진짜 축구계의 유명한 명언 중에
답답하면 니들이 뛰던지
우리 기성용 선생님께서
그치 답답하면 니들이 쓰던지
답답하면 니들이 뛰던지라고 하면 안 되겠죠
그런 말을 하면 안 되겠죠
상무님 시절에는 메일을 쓰던지
있었어요 실제로?
저희 때는 개인들이 그렇게 열심히
보고서를 많이 안 받고
그리고 보고서가 많이 나오지 않았어요
개인들한테 노출이 많이 안 됐고
그리고 셀 리포트 자체가 거의 없었고
약간 목표가 조정을 통해서
셀을 좀 넌지시 던져주는
목표가를 조금 올린다든가
안 올린다든가
느낀 게 뭐냐면
신한애널리스트 만났을 때
외사 애널리스트가 있었어요
외사들은 셀을 쓰잖아요
그래서 제가 그 형한테 물어봤어요
형은 이런 메일 안 받아?
자기는 안 받는데요
그래서 제가 왜? 이러니까
우린 레포트를 영어로 쓰잖아
그러니까
그래서 제가 좀 팁을 드리자면
셀 리포트는 없으니까
뉘앙스를 보시면 돼요
얘가 이거를 추천하지만
추천하는
아 이게 찐인지
약간 가짜로 추천하는 척 하는 건지
근데 약간 팔라고 할 때는
바이로 썼죠 분명히
바이로 하고 목표가도 올렸어
근데 뭔가 주저리주저리 써
마음은 쓰기 싫어
비문은 아닌데 뭔가 잘 안 익혀
그리고 중간에 내려가다 보면
악재들이 중간에
보고서 100이잖아요
70 정도의 뭐가 안 좋은 것들이
이만큼 있어
처음에는 아니지만
그러고 나서 슥 끝나 그냥
그러면
아 얘는 마음이 그렇지는 않구나
더 꿀팁이 있어요
컨트롤 F를 누르면
단어 찾기가 돼요
찾기 있지
거기서 뭘 입력하시면 되냐면
다만
그래 그래
그럼에도 불구하고
그거의 개수를 한번 보시면
이거 진짜 꿀팁이다
공부를 하면
먹고 살려고 거짓말을 할 수 있어요
아니 근데 매니저님은
셀 리포트 이런 거 써보신 적 없으세요?
근데 저는 이제 지수에 대해서
주로 코멘트를 많이 하다 보니까
지수에 대해서는
하락 압력이 있을 수밖에 없다
뭐 이 정도의 코멘트에 대해서는
코멘트는 좀 한 적이 있고
저희끼리는 이제 소위 뭉갠다고 하죠
뭔가 이제 끄트머리를 길게 길게 하면서
막 갑자기 전문용어 몇 개 나왔다가
아 이렇게 끝나?
라고 하는 그런 보고서들이 있습니다
여기서 한번 갈라치기 한번 해도 될까요?
어 갈라치기 고고고
그러니까 이게
애널리스트는 크게 매크로와
기업 분석을 나눠요
아 맞아 맞아
얘기를 해야 돼
그러니까 섹터 애널리스트가 있고
매크로 애널리스트가 있는데
어 맞아
섹터 하시고
저는 섹터 애널리스트
저는 매크로 출신
매크로 애널리스트죠
매크로 안에는 채권 보시는 분
혹은 주식 전략 하시는 분
그러니까 이런 분들의 특징은
목표 주가를 안 내세요
미국 주식이 어떻고
포스피가 어떻고
이런 얘기 하시니까
큰 그림에서 이제 말씀하시는 분이고
섹터 애널리스트는
담당 산업이 있어요
저 같은 경우 우주
뭐 인터넷도 보고
게임도 보는데
그러면 그 산업 안에
종목들이 있잖아요
그거를 이제 섹터 애널리스트라고 해요
그렇지
그래서 매크로랑은 좀 다른데
섹터 애널리스트 입장에서는
이 매크로 애널리스트들은
책임 없는 쾌락 같은 거
욕을 많이 안 먹어요
너무 두리뭉실해
예를 들면
금리 인하될 것 같다
라고 해서
영향을 미치는 보고서는 아니거든요
그렇지 누가 욕을 하진 않잖아
하는 총재님을 욕을 하기
근데 저희는
제가 뭘 잘못 썼다가
주가 떨어지면
제가 대역 죄인이 되어 있어요
종토방에 들어가서
컨트롤 F 누르면
난리가 납니다
재밌었던 댓글 중 하나가
제가 좀 안 좋은 제목을 썼어요
이제는 보여줘야 할 시간
댓글이 뭐다 하냐면
너나 보여줘라
그러면 매크로 애널리 보는 섹터는 어떻습니까?
아 이거 저도 좀
황당한 게 좀 많은데
매크로 애널리 볼 때 또
섹터가 좀
마음에 안 드는 구석이 있잖아요
이 섹터가 잘 되면
내 덕입니다
그렇지
아 역시 내가 분석을 잘했고
내가 종목을 잘 골랐고
막 이러는데
갑자기 주가 빠진다?
금리가 오르는 것 같아
그러니까
갑자기
나 아무것도 안 했는데
뭐 이런 식으로 가면서
갑자기
매크로 탓
되게 많이 하시죠
근데 이게 웃기네요
우리도 왜
머니코믹스도
방송할 때 시청자가 잘 나오는 게
장이 빠지면
이걸 많이 보세요
아 맞아요
내가 잘못 산 게 아니라
뭔가 문제가 있는 거야
저도 섹터를 하면서
제 섹터가 좋을 때는
나의 뷰가
근데 빠지잖아요?
매크로 팀에다가 가서
왜 빠지는 거야?
제일 많은 전화를 받는 게
오늘 왜 빠져요?
파는 사람 많은가 보다
이렇게 말할 수 없으니까
라고 할 뻔
그렇게 말할 수 없기 때문에
근데 이쪽은
그래도 주식 섹터
주식 전략이잖아요
저는 채권이나 환율
매크로에서는 조금 갈리거든요
맞아요
그때 제일 기분이 나쁜 게
주식이 빠지면
금리가 올라서
아 맞아요
자꾸 나한테 물어봐
맞아요
아니 당신들 어제까지
주식 막 얘기하고
잘났다고 하다가
주식 빠지면
금리 오르는 걸
왜 빨리 알아채지 못했어?
그리고 섹터도
우리가 알고 있는 반도체
이렇게 큰 섹터들이 있고
스몰캡이라고 부르는 게 있어요
스몰캡은 코스닥에서
좀 작은 애들
약간 커버하는
애널리스트가 한
셋, 넷?
둘?
한 명 있는 사람도 있어
아예 없는 걸 발굴하는 사람들이
그 애널리스트도 좀 달라요
아니 근데 연구원님은
반도체 이런 게
사실 핫하잖아요
반도체 뭐
호그한 날
뭐가 이슈가 있으니까
많이 막 찾잖아요
근데 우주는
이제야 떴지만
왜 반도체 같은 거 안 하고
우주에 가서
반도체 같은 거
왜 그런 걸 해서
이 고생을 하고 있냐고
이런 식으로
지금
섹터 비하하시는 건가요?
아니 아니 아니
그러니까
그걸 본인이 선택을 하신 건지
아니면 뭔가
센터장님이 이렇게
뭐 하라고 하시는 건지
아 우선은
제가 먼저 잡고 가야 될 거는
많은 분들이 이제 꿈을 안고
리서치로 이제 지원을 하실 때
나는 커서 자동차 애널리스트가 될 거야
우리나라 반도체로 완전 분석해보겠어
그런 꿈은 접으셔야 됩니다
애널리스트가 되는 방법은
두 가지가 있어요
첫 번째는
RA라는 어시스턴트로 입사를 해서
도재기간을 거친 다음에
너 한번 이제
글을 한번 써봐
기회를 줘요
내부적으로
그때 그거를 통과하면
등단을 할 수가 있어요
그렇지
보통 이 루트가
제일 정석적인 루트입니다
그게 아니면
외부에서
예를 들면 제가
건설업계를 다니다가
애널리스트 가고 싶어서
지원을 하는 거예요
아 원래 그 업계에 계시다가
그렇다고 뭐
바로 하실 수는 또 없어요
기간이 필요하거나
혹은 자격증 같은 것도
따야 되는데
대개는 첫 번째 방법으로
입문을 하시거든요
그러면 첫 번째 방법으로
입문할 때는
결국엔 등단을 하기 위해서는
위에서 승인이 내려져야 되잖아요
근데 그때도
섹터를 어떻게 기준으로 정하냐면
보통은 남는 섹터를 줘요
그렇지
티어가 있어야지
교수 자리 같은 거야
그렇죠
예를 들면
위에 자동차 애널리스트 분이 계신데
제가 자동차를 한다고 하는 것은
그분 보고 나가라고 하는 거랑 똑같아요
진짜
근데 제가 왜 그래서 우주를 했냐
전 원래 우주를 좋아했어요
뉴턴 잡지 이런 거 읽고
혼자서 RA 때
그런 걸 보고 있었는데
센터장님이
야 너 이런 거 좋아해?
너 이걸로 한번 글 써볼래?
발굴해주셨어
그건 너무 장점 중 하나가
우주로 했을 때
아무도 모르니까
내가 그렇다면
그런 줄 아시는 거예요
카르만 라인이 뭐 어쩌고 이런데
이게 뭐냐면
아 그건 그겁니다 하면서
아 그래?
그게 지금까지도 어느 정도 유지가 돼요
아니 근데 우주뿐만 아니고
게임도 하시고
네
네카오
인터넷 커버도 하시고
네
그러면은 이거를
다 지금 공부를 하시는 거예요?
다 팔로우업을 해야 되고
다 기업 분석을 하고 있습니다
제가 지금은 우주산업으로
굉장히 많은 관심을 받고 있고
추천을 드리고 있지만
저는 남는 시간이
네이버 카카오나
국내 게임사들도
다 팔로우업을 해요
그리고 관련 보고서도 쓰고 있습니다
그래요?
네이버 왜 이런 겁니까?
그러니까
근데 실제로 그런 거 있어요?
예를 들면
내가 방송이나
리포트를
리포트를 통해서
안 좋게 얘기를 했어
그러면은 거기
기업 탐방을 가잖아요 보통
네
어사가 되잖아요
자 한 잔 하고 얘기해
어떤 일화가 있냐면
어떤 모 애널리스트가
거기가 좀 뭔가 이슈가 있었어요
그래서 모 애널리스트가
그거 관련해서
리포트를 썼어요
근데 거기 IR 담당자가
이 사람 연락받지마
오
그런 경우가
왕왕 있어요
그래서 리포트를 쓸 때도
이제는 보여줘야 할 시간
정도로
마감을 하는 게
좋은데
이제는 팔아야 할 시간
뭐
라고 해버리면
안 되지 그거
그건 정말
그 기업장에서 서운한 거죠
보여줘야 할 시간으로
해도 충분히 알아들을 텐데
꼭 그랬어야만
했냐
라고
될 수가 있는 거니까
이제는 팔아야 할 시간
쓸 수 있어요?
제목을?
아 쉽지 않죠
옛날 얘기예요
제가 2010년도 초
야드에 갔는데
안 들어 보내줘
다 같이 이제
애널리스트 지방에 내려가니까
밖에서 이렇게 서 있다가
다른 애널리스트들
투어하고 올 때까지
기다리고 있다가
이러니까 셀리포트를
어떻게 쓰냐고
사람들도 싫어하지
기업도 싫어하지
회사도 별로 안 좋아요
회사도 그렇게 나쁜 이미지로
각인되는 걸 안 좋아하기 때문에
그래서 셀리포트 쓰시는 분들
정말 대단한 분들이세요
진짜
그렇죠
8년 전쯤
굉장히 유명한
제약바이오 섹터에
쇼트 보고서가 있었습니다
그걸 쓰셨던 분이
제 선배님이셨는데
그걸 쓰시고 나서
굉장히 많은 어떤 협박과
회사 1층에서
피켓 들고 기다리고 계세요
저 그거 봤어요
여의도에서 쫓아가는
2차전지 때
그러니까 이러니까 개미들은
보고서 좀 정직하게 써라 하는데
막상 들어보면
그래서 제가 이 자리를 빌어서
하나 건의 드리고 싶은 게
건의 그래
의사 집단도 의협이 있잖아요
애협
아
다
있는데 의사 협회처럼
애협 차원에서의
적극적인 어떤
아 단체 행동을
단체 행동을
애널리스트 단체 행동을 한다고
모이라고 그래
아무도 안 해요
한 명도 안 할걸요
다 야근하고 있어
다 너무 개인 사업자시오
다 개인적인 생각에 긴장돼
맞아요
애협 차원에서 예를 들면
금요일 오후 4시는
증자 금지
왜냐면 무조건 야근을 해야 되니까
예를 들면
금요일 오후 4시
실적 발표 금지
그때 하는 이유가 있잖아요
맞아요
이유가 있죠
사람들 모르게 넘어가고 싶은 거잖아
아
무슨 일이 터지면
뭐 12시에 뭐가 터져
다음날 아침 회의에 그걸 얘기해야 돼요
매니저들한테 그게 가니까
밤새서 하는 거야
아침에 전체 회의 하거든요
거기 이제 브로커들 들어오시는 데도 있고
안 들어오는 데도 있는데
브로커가 듣고 기관 가야 되고
이미 보고서가 7시에 다 예약 걸어놓죠
그래서 나가야 돼요
아니 근데 얘기가 나온 김에
애널리스트들이 여의도에서 가장 빡센 일과로 약간 유명하던데
옛날 얘기인 건지
하루 루틴이 어떻게 되는지 좀 알려주세요
저희는 그래도 저희가 처음에 일하고 나서
주 52시간제라고 하는 게 도입이 됐고
그 이후로는 조금 그래도 모닝 미팅도 한 30분 미뤄지고
아 그래요?
아직 모닝 미팅이란 게 있어요
모든 증권사들은 장 시작 전에
전 애널리스트들 그리고 법인 영업 분들을 모시고
기다란 테이블 주르르르르르르
저 증권사 유튜브에서 봤어요
한 오전 7시 8시 때 미팅하시는 거
미팅을 하면서 그날 발간한 자료에 대한 코멘트
내가 이런 이런 자료를 발간했고
이거에 대한 포인트는 뭐다
그런 것들을 다 발표를 하고
질의응답을 가지는 그거를 매일매일 합니다
매일요?
네 매일
원래는 그래서 한 6시 반쯤에 이제 출근을 해서
오탈자라든지
뭐 이런 것들 체크를 해가지고
뭐 이상이 없는지
그다음에 혹시나 아침에 이제 미국장 끝난 거에서
뭔가 내가 얘기하는 거랑 달라지는 부분 없는지까지 확인하고
7시에 보통 발간을
7시에 발간을 하려면
몇 시에 일어나서 몇 시에 그걸 준비하는
그래서 보통 많은 분들이 여의도 근처로 많이 이사를 오세요
전날 다 써놓고
거의 다 써놓고 이제 마무리만 하고
근데 내 섹터인데 몰라
왜 옳는지 몰라
그러면 거기서 엄청 까이는 거
거기서는 아까에도 끝나고 나서 센터장이 이리 와 와라
제가 RA예요
애널리스트 자료를 발간을 해야 되는데
제가 결정적인 실수를 했어요
한 달짜리 예를 들면 못 고치거나
업데이트를 잘못했어
근데 모닝 미팅에서 그거를 센터장님이 짚었어
그 담당 애널리스트가 약간 변명을 하는데
아린이 옆에서
예전에는 그랬어요
그냥 뭐 그 실수할 수 있는
그거는 이제
닌닌도 주체 못하는 분노가 일으킬 때 있잖아요
애널리스트분들이 그런 거에 되게 예민해
본인 레포트에 실수가 들어가는 거를
자존심이 엄청 상해요
프라임 매니저들은 좀 다혈질이 많아서
막 소리 지르고
그리고 끝나요. 애널리스트는 5시간 세워놓고 갈굽니다.
RA면 여기 세워놓고 계속 갈굽니다.
하루 종일 사람들 다 있는 데서
어? 그러셨던 거예요?
제가 그래서 아는 잡돌이 썰 중에 제일 흥미로운 거
기업들이 실적 발표를 하잖아요.
그럼 저희가 실적 발표 컨퍼런스 콜에 참여를 해요.
요즘은 되게 시스템이 잘 갖춰져 있어서
제가 그냥 참석을 한다고 하더라도
자동적으로 음소거가 돼요.
예전에는 단체로 들어가서
제가 음소거를 안 누르면 소리가 나오던 시절이었어요.
이제 모 애널리스트가 음소거를 안 누르신 거예요.
제가 그때는 RA였거든요.
저는 이제 자리에서 이걸 들으면서
받아 써야 되니까 이러고 있고
옆에 애널리스트분은 본인도 이제 들어야 되니까 이렇게 듣고 있고
실적 발표 시작하잖아요.
지금부터 실적 발표 시작하겠습니다.
1분기 매출액은 얼마고 이런데
음소거를 안 한 애널리스트가 RA로 혼내기 시작한 거예요.
와 잡돌이가 생중계됐구나.
문제는 이 애널리스트는 에어폰을 안 끼고 RA로 혼내니까
본인이 이게 들어가는 줄 모르고
야 너 일로 와봐. 장난해?
근데 그거를 이렇게 하고 있다가
응.
나도 모르게.
근데 더 웃긴 거는 거기 IR 담당자가 진행을 하고 계시잖아요.
음소거를 해주시고
다 받았죠.
근데 사실 그렇게 할 땐 센터 정도 못 건들잖아요.
RA 잡돌이 할 때는 아무도 못 건들어.
왜요? 왜 못 건들어요?
내 RA 나만 건드릴 수 있어요. 약간.
선후배가 확실하거나?
그리고 나서 제 옆에 있는 애널리스트가
우윤아 들었지?
내가 너 혼내는 건 혼내는 것도 아니야.
맞아.
PD야 들었지?
여의도에 최근에 관심들도 높아지고
어떻게 약간 위상이 올라간 것 같으세요?
위상이 올라갔다기보다는
저는 근데 애널리스트의 장점 중 하나가
전문가로서 인정받는 게 큰 것 같아요.
그래도
증권사 애널리스트로서 열심히 공부를 하고 자료를 내면서
이게 공식적으로 발간되는 거다 보니까
공적인 자리에 나갈 수 있었을 때
전문성을 좀 인정받는 거는
증권업의 마지막 양심.
보고서를 쓰는 애널리스트는
아무리 어려도
연구원님, 위원님, 사장님도 그래요.
연금에 가도.
인정하는 거지.
너는 고생을 하고
너는 너의 모든 걸 정수를 녹여서
너의 양심을 걸고
네 얼굴을 걸고 보고서를 썼기 때문에
난 그건 인정한다.
그런데 셀레포트를 써 이 새끼야?
이런 생각이 들었어요.
갑자기.
내가 들고 있는데.
이놈의 새끼.
현대차 이만큼이 있는데.
인정은 하지만 욕은 해주겠다.
애널리스트 일 중에 굉장히 큰일이 욕먹는 거예요.
맞아요.
아니 근데 사실 제가
최근에 재미나이한테 종목 상담을 되게 많이 하거든요.
차트 분석도 잘하고
팔아라, 사라, 지지선, 손절라인
이런 것까지 다 얘기해줘요.
이런 걸 보면서
아니 애널리스트가 앞으로
어어?
아니 근데 그래서 내가 모르는 어떤 또
여의도만의 어떤 생태계가 또 있을 것 같기는 해요.
생존의 어떤 비법.
네 말씀하신 부분.
이 부분이 정확해요.
저희도 업계에서 AI의 위협을 많이 받아요.
그래서 제가 생각했을 때는
향후의 애널리스트라는 직업들도
좀 이런 부분에 대해서 자각심을 가지고
본인의 브랜드를 좀 더 키우는 방향으로 가야 되지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있어요.
아니 댓글에 안 돼.
그럼 욕은 누가 먹어.
애널리스트는 약간 AI가 못해주는 게 있어요.
그러니까 매니저들의 심리상담자.
아 맞아요.
또는 정신과 의사 같은.
맞아요.
진짜 멘탈 케어.
매니저들도 이 애널리스트가 생각하기엔 나랑 똑같아.
둘이 아이고.
그랬는데 뭐.
못 올라.
어떡하지.
누가 문제야.
걔 본부장의 문제지.
막 그런 거.
신세 안타.
어.
그러면 매니저가 또 풀려 이렇게.
그리고 AI는 A라는 뷰를 제시했을 때
아니야 B잖아 B잖아 B잖아 이러면
B로 또 바꾸잖아요.
그래.
근데 애널리스트도 그래요.
변상의 내고 계속 B잖아 B잖아 B잖아 하면
B일 수도 있습니다.
그만해주세요.
귀에 피납니다.
멈춰주세요.
매크로 애널리스트는 그렇게 뷰를 내면
모델 내놓으라고.
아.
있지.
있는데 약간 보여줄 정도는 아니잖아.
맞아요.
근데 그 모델은 정말
개인의 어떻게 보면
민낯이에요.
그쵸.
논리적이지 않은 부분도 분명히 있습니다.
예를 들면 리니지 클래식이 출시가 돼요.
하루에 매출 얼마 될 것 같냐.
이거 약간 애널리스트 업계 전체에 대한 자세.
소프트웨어가 유독 그래요.
예를 들면 자동차나 반도체나 이런 부분들은
유의미하게 논조를 만들어갈 수 있거든요.
데이터도 있고 수요의 지급.
근데 리니지 클래식은 얼마를 벌까를 설명을 하려면
어렵지.
이게 저희도 어려움이 많습니다.
그럴 때는 어떻게 합니까?
그러니까 리니지 클래식을 예를 들면
기존에 있던 리니지 작들은 초기 1매출이 얼마였는지
혹은 최근에 출시된 유사한 게임의 1매출이 어느 정도 나왔는지
그 유사한 출시된 게임들이 초반에 있던 출시 지표
혹은 출시 전에 있었던 트래픽 이런 것들을 비교해서
이거에 비례해서 이 정도는 프리미엄을 줄 수 있다.
아 애매한데?
그쵸. 근데 애매할 수밖에 없어요.
네. 그러니까.
그러고 이제 숫자를 어쨌든 정해.
어떻게 어떻게 정해.
그치.
그러면 이제 딱 눈치를 보고
저는 그 정도까지는 아닌데
저는 다른 증권사 리포트를 읽죠.
나랑 피어그룹이 맞춰야 돼요?
그래서 내가 너무 피어.
그럼 좀 낮추고.
애널리스트 리포트를 정말 열심히 읽는 분들은 애널리스트들이에요.
다른 분들의 뷰도 되게 중요해요.
커닝을 또 해야 되니까.
참고.
아 이런 식으로 밸류에이션에 접근을 하셨구나.
나도 다음번에 참고해야겠다.
근데 기호는 그렇다 쳐.
응.
매크로는 더
지수 얼마까지 가나요?
이런 거 딱 질문 받으면
아 잠시만요.
제가 엑셀을 어디
어떻게 산출하냐고.
뭐 나름 이제 저희도 뭐 추정을 하죠.
윤쌤이
예전에 나와서 하신 말씀이
야 쟤는 냅둬.
이게 두 가지 의미가 있어요.
하나는 알아서 잘하고
쟤는 좋아하는 매니아층이 있으니까
그냥 내버려 두고 있고
또 하나는 윤쌤이 이제 주식전략 하시니까
하우스뷰를 정립하셔야 되는데
윤쌤이 볼 때는 금리가 하락해.
나는 금리 오른다는 보고서를 쓰는 거예요.
채권 쪽에서.
하우스뷰를 다르게 가져가요?
아니 난 모르고 썼지.
나한테 얘기를 안 해주니까
나한테 얘기를 안 해주고
윤쌤이 나한테 얘기해주겠어요?
그래서 오른 걸 써서 가져가.
근데
왜냐면 이게 전략팀이 같이 나가야 되는데
같이 가서 세미나 해야 되는데
주식전략하는 양반은
금리가 내려갈 테니까
금리 인하해줄 테니까 주식이 올라갈 겁니다.
라고 하려고 준비했는데
내가 금리 오른다고 한 거야.
넌 다음에 와라.
몇 번 그러니까 그냥 야 쟤는 내버려 둬라.
냅두라고.
알상농네.
그래서 약간
매크로나 주식전략은
하우스뷰에 영향을 받아요.
섹터도 근데 영향을 좀 받아.
큰 섹터들은.
주식이 날라간다고 했는데
삼성전자 하락하는데
이렇게 할 수가 없는 거예요.
근데 그게 자기의 소신일 수도 있잖아요.
막내 PD님이 들어오셨는데
니뉴님한테
저희 프로그램 방향성 그거 아닌 거 같은데요?
개미는 지금
그거 좀 아닌 거 같아요.
저는 그렇게 생각 안 하고
이렇게 가시죠.
뭐라고 말씀하실까요?
그렇게 말을 할 수 있다고?
그러니까요.
그래서 제가 아까 상무님한테
하우스뷔라
그걸 하신 분이시구나.
그걸 하신 거예요.
자르시던가.
제가 원래 그때
마지못해 있었거든요.
매크로에널이 없어가지고
저 원래 프랍하다가
나가려고 했는데
매크로에널이 없어서
제가 에너지 자격증이 있으니까
잠깐 있어라 하고
보팅 들어가려면
구석을 맞춰야 되니까
매크로에널이 없습니다.
그런데 어떻게 국민연금 보팅을 들어가.
그래서 제가 앉아 있었는데
어느
보고서를 쓰라는 거예요.
보고서를 쓰라고요?
쓰다 보니까 그렇게 된 거예요.
자르시던가.
제가 볼 때는 위원님도 약간
좀 그런 깔 아닌가요?
우주는 뷰가
저 말고는 없어요.
그렇지.
보팅을 그럼 뭘로 받아요?
보팅을 우주는 못 받죠.
보팅 받는 게 뭐예요?
많으면 1년에 2번
언론사에서 투표를 받습니다.
베스트 애널들.
네 맞아요.
그걸 이제 폴이라고.
그걸 누가 뽑아요 그러면?
이제 저희 같은
이제 뭐 매니저들이나.
그러면 의원 매니저님한테
한 표 주셔야겠네요.
어떤 사람한테 폴을 주겠어요?
평소에 친한 사람?
그러니까 이제 그 사람마다 다른 거죠.
실력은 비슷할 것 같은데?
아닌가?
아니야 아니야.
아니에요?
확실히 차이가 나요.
내가 돈 버는데
도움을 주는 애널리스트가 있어요.
맞아요.
브로커도 있고.
나랑 합의 잘 맞든
아니면 걔가 잘하든.
근데 그건 어쩔 수 없이 티가 나.
근데 그런 것도 있죠.
예를 들면 니디님의 매니저예요.
저희 둘이 애널리스트인데
이 사람 뷰가 너무 정확하고
너무 잘 맞는데
제가 니디님한테 많이 도움을 줘요.
예를 들면 니디님이
필요한 자료도 보내주고
니디님이 전화 와가지고
왜 빠지냐고 물어볼 때마다
되도 않는 이유라도 설명을 해주고
니디님이 짜증 낼 때도
아 죄송합니다.
만약에 그렇게 했을 때는
마음이 더 갈 수가 있잖아요.
아 맞네.
그러나 그럼에도 불구하고
이제 YTD로 펀드 수익률 찍어본 다음에
종목 순으로 이제 기여도를 체크해서
아 이분은 안 줄 수가 없다.
세미나 잡자고 해도
연락도 좀 잘 안 받으시고
막 맨날 바쁘시고 이래도
숫자는 거짓말을 할 수가 없다.
비슷하면 뭐
팔이 좀 안으로 굽을 수는 있겠죠.
근데 이놈이 셀리포트 썼어.
그니까.
그 타이밍이 내가 들고 있다가 무너진 짓이야.
그러면
체크해놨다가
0표
아니면 내 옆에 친구한테 그래.
심지어 팀에서 아예 한 표도 안 주는 경우도 있어.
아 맞아요.
얘는 절대 주지 마.
얘는 떨어뜨려야 돼.
오히려 그분의 경쟁자한테 표를 몰아줘서
그분의 등수가 올라가게끔
아 여기도 왜 이렇게 무서워요?
와 진짜 여기 정글이다.
되게 무서운 사람들이야.
진짜 무서운 사람들이네.
거기서 살아남아야 된다고.
그니까 영업력도 좋아야 되고
자기 실력도 좋아야 되고
근데 그런 분이면 개투를 하고 싶을 것 같기도 해요.
왜냐면 내가 일단 정보가 되게 많잖아요.
저는 그런 생각 많이 해요.
예?
단 뭐가 있냐면 내가 이 자리에 있으니까
내가 애널리스트를 하고 있으니까
그게 좀 보이고
그런 정보들이 좀 더 빠르고
만약에 내가 정말 개미로 나갔을 때
이 정도 퍼포먼스를 유지할 수 있는
어떤 인사이트나 뷰가 될까?
그건 좀 무서운 거죠.
그래서 나랑 슈카영이 그 종목을 많이 못 사는 게 그런 거예요.
채화돼서
채택되어가지고
방송에서 또 얘기하고
내가 말하는 걸 못 사는 거야.
아 맞아요.
이게 제일 현대화야.
몸에 배요 그게.
현대화가 있어도 못 사고
나와서 유튜브 하면 또 못 사고
언제 사는 거야?
아니 저 궁금한데 유튜브 하면 못 사요?
좋아 보인다고 말했는데
우연찮게 내가 10억 들고 있어.
그런데 그게 막 내일부터 상한가를 막 쳐.
근데 금감원이 살짝 와서
어? 이때 얘기했는데 여기서부터 올라가네요?
근데 요즘에는 저도 좀 그런 부분이 있는 게
요즘에는 텔레 채널들이
아 그렇죠.
제가 좀 짜증나는 경우는
이번 1분기 실적 안 좋아.
이걸 돌려버리는 거예요.
그 출처가 어딘지도 모르고
모르죠. 받은 글 형태로 돌아가버리니까.
저 입장에서는 이거를 증명을 하려면
출처가 있어야 되는데 출처도 없고
아 그러니까 찌라시를 반박을 해야 되는 거네.
근데 또 걱정되는 거는
내가 모르는 뭔가가 있나?
그렇지.
아 그렇지.
맞아 맞아.
나 빼고 다 아는 건데.
나만 지금 엉땅한 거야?
여유도 있으면 장점이
받은 글은 많이 받아요.
80%가 불륜 글이고요.
10%도 누가 돈 많이 벌었다고 그리고
나머지 5%가 이제 뭐 주식과 관련된 글.
불륜 뜨면 난리난다?
더더가 되고.
최종일 메신저에서 그 얘기만 한다?
어제 누가 누구랑 싸웠단다.
술자리에서 난리 났단다.
독탐이 미쳤네.
왜냐면 너무 좁아요.
알상무님 유령처럼 돌아다니는 거.
제가 받은 글로 돌리는 거예요.
알상무 유령처럼 돌아다니는 거.
아는 척하기 싫어서 얼굴 내리고 다닙니다.
이런 식으로 돌리고.
그러면 아 대인기피증이 있으신가 보다.
알상무 대인기피증.
그렇게 야마가 그렇게 돌리는구나.
저 있으면 알상무 이호남.
대인기피증 심화로 이호남.
그 이제 바로 생활고에 시달립니다.
맞아요.
이런 식으로.
그래서 실제로 본인이 아니라고
해명문을 작성한 경우도 있어요.
맞아 맞아.
아니 다들 너무 업계가 좁으니까 사실.
그리고 예를 들면 얘기를 하다가
A라는 사람을 좀 욕을 봤어요.
바로 다음날
어? 은윤아 미안해.
내가 뭐 그렇게 서운했니?
그러니까 여의도에서는 말을 조심을 해야 되고
누구 욕을 함부로 하면 안 되고.
애널리스트들은 그 정보도 중요해.
어떤 매니저가 어디로 이직한단다.
근데 그 매니저 스타일이 있으니까.
큰 펀드 옮기면 이 펀드에서
동일히 큰 펀드로 가는데
그러면 오토로 바꿀 거 아니에요.
그러면 아 이 종목 가는구나.
그럼 이직하는 것도 소문이 바로 나겠네요?
바로 나요.
누가 어디서 어디로 간다.
래퓨체크 들어올 때부터 알아.
예를 들면 이런 거예요.
제가 이직을 하게 됐어요.
최종 오퍼를 받았어요.
전 아무한테도 말 안 했어요.
대석이 형한테만 말했어요.
센터장님 시험에 들어가요.
딕 딕 딕.
그러면 이미 알고 계세요.
그치.
어 들어와.
그리고 앉자마자
얼만데.
어디로 가는지 이미 알고 계시는 거예요.
그러면 이제 주절주절 또 애널리스트 특.
아 제가 그쪽에서 어떤 그런 뷰나 이런 부분들 좋게 봐주셔서
됐고
얼마냐고.
그냥 이따 듣고
기다 아니다가 나온 거예요.
그래 고생했다.
그러면 이제 나가는 거고요.
그래서 인성도 되게 중요합니다.
착하게 살아야 돼.
여의도 사람들 다 착해요?
저는 여의도가 그냥 그 인간 군상을
제일 잘 보여주고
해주는 어떤
근데 펀드매니저님은 그러면 뭘 잘해야 돼요?
대응이 항상 제일 중요하거든요.
대응.
와서 느낀 게
우리는 인베스터가 아니라 매니저다.
어떤 좋은 종목을 발굴해서
거기에 투자해서
그 기업이 30년 40년
워런 부피의 어르신처럼 이제 계속 잘 되고
이러면 이제 투자자의 길로 가는 거고
저희는 이 포트폴리오를 관리하면서
예상치 못한 어떤 이슈들이 생겼을 때 대응하고
내 생각과 시장이 다르게 움직였을 때 대응하고
이런 대응을 계속해야 되는
애널리스트는 뭘 가장 명예롭게 여길까요?
저는 무조건 맞추는 거
저는 연봉이요.
결국 프로잖아요.
프로는 연봉으로 말하는 거고
연봉을 많이 받기 위해서
열심히 일하는 거라고 생각합니다.
저는 애널리스트 할 때 제일 뿌듯했던 때가
내가 모르는 매니저나
약간 큰 기관 매니저가 전화해서
누구누구인데
어디서 좋았는데요?
이러고 딱 끊어.
한번 봅시다. 이렇게 하고
세미나 요청도 아니고 밥 먹으러 오라고 그래요.
밥을 그냥 먹으면서 얘기하는 게 내가 궁금한 거지.
근데 저도 이런 적 있어요.
모 대표님 연락이 오신 거예요.
밥을 먹죠.
스카우트
근데 정말 투자와 관련된 거 물어보시더라고요.
어떻게 생각하냐 해가지고
잘 봤네
밥만 먹다가
와 오늘 애널리스트 특집으로 해봤는데
와 오늘 역대급입니다.
진짜 재밌었어요.
저 한 가지 부탁드려도 되나요?
어 그럼요.
7월 초에 책을 발간을 하거든요.
역시 자기 브랜딩
잠깐만요. 지금 여기 시청자분들 몇 분 계시죠?
8,400분
여기서 사셔야 됩니다.
무료 마케팅을 돈 안 내고 지금 광고를 하고 있어요.
오늘 또 아이상모님 후배 애널리스트님과 함께 해보셨는데
근데 후배라기보다는
사실 애널리스트는 위아래가 별로 없어요.
아니 뭐 존경하는 3대 애널리스트라고
존경은 그냥 하는 건데
원래 애널리스트는 사실 동등한 존재인 거예요.
섹터가 다르고 그러면
먼저 했을 뿐이지
그리고 이미 자리를 잡으신 분들이기 때문에
역시 그릇이 달라
그러나
역시 3대 역시 3대 애널리스트
그래서 이분들이 여기 와서 이렇게 웃기게 얘기하고 있긴 하지만
굉장히 자기 자신을 정말 뼈를 깎는
그러니까 애널리스트가
그렇게 막
이렇게 우스운 존재가 아니에요.
아까 봤잖아요. 주식 안 산다니까
살 수 있지만 안 산다.
우리나라 애널은 그래도 굉장히
모랄이 괜찮아요.
못 맞춰서 그렇지
사람들은 착해
못 맞추는 건 어떡하냐
애는 착해
착하고 믿으셔도 됩니다.
오늘 나와주신 두 분
아 너무 감사드립니다.
그럼 오늘 개미는 지금은 여기까지 하도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.